hello hello everyone and welcome back to
chess openings explained
as always my name is caleb denby and
tonight i'm going to be taking you
through
some pretty exciting games and uh some
other pretty exciting games from two
very different eras we are going to take
a look at some of the openings that the
masters of old used to play back in the
19th century for the most part
uh during the romantic era of chess so
we're gonna see
how they approached the opening what
sorts of ideas that
they had that made their games so
romantic and then we're gonna take a
look at some games
from modern day grand masters in similar
or the same openings and see
some of the differences in their
approaches here
but without further ado why don't we
just jump on
over to it up first i'm going to show
you a game
between two players that were around in
the 1800s
they i don't believe they were by by any
means like the best the best in the
1800s
but this game was very indicative of how
many games
during that time period uh did tend to
go so i wanted to start with it because
it's it's a pretty fun one
so we have jose tulosa carreras uh with
white pieces
and jean uh carbo e
i'm not b-a-t-l-l-e good luck
pronouncing that
if you're not french i or spanish
something i don't know
anyways enough of me embarrassing myself
let's talk about the chess
we have e4 e5 so far so normal doesn't
matter if you're in the year
1400 or the year 2020 this is how a lot
of your chess games are gonna start
and then knight c3 so already
starting to deviate a bit from what is
the super super super most popular
opening
uh in present day times so i wanted to
ask the chat
what do you think knight c3 is
indicative of
as i actually pull open the chat here
to see what you guys are saying so
knight c3 what does this really indicate
both in the romantic era and in present
day
what what is what is happening here and
yes steve north has the right idea and
harry bowman
also on the right track whenever you're
playing with the black pieces for those
of you a little bit newer
to this sorts these sorts of ideas if
you see your opponent
start with knight c3 and not knight f3
you shouldn't assume
that everything is business as usual
because generally this is the better
knight to develop it creates a threat
while developing at the same time it
seems like the ideal move
so for white to play knight c3 instead
usually there's a pretty good reason in
this case as the chat is saying
it indicates that white may be looking
to play the vienna gambit which involves
launching the f pawn forward similar to
the king's gambit with f2 to f4 and so
this is the reason why white avoids
playing knight f3
they want to give this f pawn some
mobility and
you know allow this f2 to f4 idea
uh to to remain in the game so black
replies with net f6
and this is still normal to to modern
day uh chess games this is
perfectly reasonable by both sides so
far and then white does go ahead and
enter
the vienna gambit which you absolutely
can do
in modern day chess so does anybody in
the chat
know how modern day players tend to
respond
to the vienna gambit before we get into
what actually happens in this in this
game
uh what tends to happen nowadays
and yeah harry bowman has the right idea
so when uh white is going a little bit
crazy
uh with stuff like f4 weakening some
squares
the the right idea tends to be to open
things up
right what black has spent all the moves
developing white is playing a slightly
strange f2f4 move
weakening diagonals weakening the king a
little bit and
black wants to not get rolled over in
the center so black should reply
with the move d5 opening up the bishop
opening up the queen's access to the
game and sort of just fighting back not
backing away
from what from what white is doing but
you'll notice
uh many many many games in the romantic
era
tend to take on a very similar uh a very
similar feel all of the games
tend to go in a similar direction and
that direction is
uh it was thought that that black's duty
was to sort of sit back and defend just
by nature of having to move second
and it was white's duty to sacrifice as
much material as
possible in order to quickly get at the
black king and deliver checkmate
and so i think we see a little bit of
that going on here
d5 is just far too active
for black to be playing black needs to
develop the pieces
and capture any free material offered to
him uh
and that's sort of quote unquote how
you're supposed to play chess
during the romantic era white on the
attack and
black on the defensive just because
white gets to move first
now in the game black makes a pretty
awful move which is bishop b4
and i don't really have an explanation
for
this sequence of moves here uh for some
reason
neither player believed that uh that f
takes e5
was a strong enough threat to to be real
uh
i don't know why either player thought
this f-take c5 i think
can and should have been played uh this
isn't really doing much
for uh four black and white is just
going to keep this extra strong pawn on
e5 this knight is going to be very
awkward
white is going to be winning on the king
side and this itself could have
you know very possibly been another
romantic era game that just never got
written down
but in this game white said i don't care
about your e5 pawn i
am here to checkmate you and just
develops the pieces right just goes for
rapid rapid rapid development
and that's what you're going to see in a
lot of uh
1800s games so bishop c4 played on the
board
black takes on c3 we see take back on c3
and now black actually does come up with
the move of d5
and this is a very interesting idea uh
in this case though it's still not quite
correct
uh here you know free pawns are free and
this is something that that also does
happen in a lot of romantic
era games that they just didn't have as
much regard for the value
of of material they just really didn't
because
all their games are ending in 15 moves
everybody's getting checkmated before
move 20
so who cares about a free pawn but
turns out free pawns are good so black
should have just taken instead we see
the move d5
uh e takes d5 is played by white and
this is not because white isn't
interested in capturing pawns white is
just interested in keeping this diagonal
open and the only way to do that is to
get rid of this annoying d5 pawn in the
way
we see black capturing back and now
queen f3
so white finally is saying please please
please
just take my f-pawn i've been trying to
gambit it this entire game
and you've just refused to capture it so
black eventually now
does say yes i will take your free pawn
and now we see a classic romantic
romantic era developing plan
bishop c1 to a3 this appears so
so often in romantic era games partly
because of the popularity of the evans
gambit back in the day
opening up this diagonal for the bishop
but this is how a lot
of mating attacks really do get started
in these 1800s games you see white
planting a bishop on a3
black getting stuck with this king in
the center
and just never being able to to finish
development
but now uh black to move and play chat i
want to see if you can play better
than jon uh yon carbo here
god i should have i don't know why i
don't look these names up before the
lecture
but like just just as a stupid english
speaker
just looking at these three names like
what am i supposed to do with that i'm
going to call them carbo because i'm
pretty sure i'm pronouncing carbo close
to
close to correctly so carbo do better
than carbo here
what can you do
and as always the chat is coming to my
rescue here with all of the historical
background on the game
apparently uh carreras was a student of
butler carbo of carbo and
the eventual teacher of lucena
interesting interesting stuff
so there are some strange suggestions
queen takes d2 i don't think is quite
correct
uh that would be met with king takes d2
with an extra queen
knight e6 has been suggested which is
interesting
and yeah uh it's actually not so easy to
find the absolute best moves here for
uh for black and that's mainly because
white does actually have a lot of
annoying pressure so
how do you approach a position like this
you are
seemingly up a free pawn but there are
some issues
in your way before you can develop your
pieces for example if you play bishop e6
you are
very much leaving this pawn on b7 in the
dust
so it's not immediately clear how you
should finish development
how you can ensure that your kings is
going to remain safe
but it turns out the best way to go is
to simply start with knight c6
blocking this diagonal from white's
queen following up with bishop e6
and then eventually going something uh
like a queen developing move
and potentially even castling on the
queen side getting the king out of the
center in this manner
and launching a counter attack against
white's king as well
but uh carbo actually found a very very
interesting way to continue the game
with knight takes g2 check uh going for
a tactic
and yeah harry bowman actually does see
this tactic i was gonna say
nobody in the chat actually came up with
this one but harry
was there just in time so yeah the
problem with bishop e6
uh is as i stated you leave the b7 pawn
behind which is why knight c6 first and
then bishop b6 is the way to go
uh why is this the best way to go well
because black
is a material all you need to do is find
the path to finish it to finish
development
without giving up too much in the way of
king safety or material back
and knight c6 and bishop b6 is a
perfectly fine way to do that
sometimes simple moves are correct uh
and that idea of simple moves being
correct is something
that the romantic players didn't have a
huge fondness for
they liked crazy tactics and ending the
games in style
hence romantic era but knight takes g2
that is the crazy tactic indicative of
the aromantic era game
just launching or ripping open the
fourth rank here
and allowing black to to play a tactic
gaining even more material
uh what's more romantic than playing
with the black pieces and taking every
free pawn
your heart desires so we do see queen
takes g2
queen h4 check queen g3
by white better than moving the king to
keep the castling rights
queen takes c4 and then the reason why
black's tactic
isn't actually so good is because after
queen takes g7
all of a sudden uh black stroke on h8 is
falling there's no way to defend it so
if
we were in a modern uh era of
boring draws this is the point where the
player with the black pieces would say
hey wait a second my rook on h8 is going
to die
and then my king is going to die because
it has nowhere to hide
and all of the squares around it are
attacked
and so the player with the back black
pieces would likely go
check check check check check
check check and the game would end in a
draw
but not the romantic people the romantic
people say
who cares if my rook is falling your
rook is falling
okay you are the one who should be
afraid so we see queenie for check
king f2 and queen takes h1 of course
classic
queen takes h1 now who sees
the romantic way to continue the game
here
who sees how to uh how to win the game
with white here fans of yasser sarawan
may find this move fans of yasser sarwan
so yes of course queen takes h8 is good
enough
queen takes e5 is of course not the way
to go
allowing black to develop while
defending with bishop e6
but knight f3 yasser sarawan fans all
love to scream
take my rooks and black complies takes
the rook
and now it is of course uh checkmate in
just a few moves here we see queen takes
h8
king d7 and the reason why we included
knight f3
is now knight takes c5 check king e6
and after check check
uh trying to force king takes e5
when d4 check would come but first
bishop e6
queen f3 king e5 and now d4 check
does end the game uh with checkmate in
the center of the board
as so often happens in these romantic
games
so this i think is is the quintessential
uh romantic era game and what i mean by
that is while these are not the most
famous romantic era players
this this is your pure romance
game not necessarily the best moves
being played on every turn
but black going crazy trying to take all
the rooks
and white getting checkmate with that
slightest bit of
extra development and that is what the
romantic era games are all about
not necessarily great chess games in the
sense that they are
you know practically correct and you
know purely
good moves but they are very fun fun to
see
and there are some tactics that these
players find that that are
pretty interesting to to think about
today right not a lot of players
would in this position with black be
thinking hey wait a second i can take
all the rooks here and maybe i'll win
uh everybody's gonna be saying i'm
afraid for my life
get get me out of this chess game so uh
kudos to carbo for
not going for the repetition i don't
even know if repetition was a thing
when these players were playing like uh
i'm sure there were ways to to draw the
chess game
but i think this was back at a time when
you know what what are you going to go
for a repetition in the romantic era
ridiculous
so that was this game just to recap we
have
strangely black hanging upon on e5 in
the opening and white just developing a
bishop
instead because why not we get this uh
bishop takes c3b takes c3 idea
trying to loosen up the d5 square
but now uh white is able to get the
classic romantic era squeeze with the
bishop on a3
black does not find the way to develop
out of the attack
instead going for more questionable
tactics
which eventually lead to black having to
go for a forced draw
and instead taking all the rooks and
dying in style
as you often do okay so let's take a
look
at another example of the vienna game
oops spoilers don't look
don't look another example of the vienna
game from some modern day
grand masters
so for our modern day grand masters we
are going to be looking
at the one and only ivan chuck against
svidler uh and we start off the same way
with e4 e5 knight c3 knight f6 and f4
but now you are going to have to look
pretty hard
to find somebody who's not playing d5
against you in this position
the days of old when you could just hope
for bishop b4
hanging in e5 pawn are pretty much gone
here
uh your opponents are going to to be
wise to this idea
if you're super lucky you might find
somebody playing d6 or knight c6 here
but more often than not they're going to
play d5 and at the top level
that's pretty much exclusively what
they're going to be playing
and now in this game we actually see
kramnik introducing what i think was a
fairly new line
at the time and this is only back in
2009 so not like eons ago
but e takes d5 was kramnik's move the
main line by far
is f takes e5 when you can go down some
reasonably boring theory
but uh did i say kramnik ivan chuck
introduced this move e takes d5 now i
might be wrong in that i don't know for
certain that chucky was the first person
to play this move but uh definitely it
was newer at the time back in 2009 and
maybe i'm totally wrong
and they were playing this for decades
but i couldn't find too many games
so e takes d5 rather than the main move
f takes e5
and this is a pretty romantic move
believe it or not uh
this is a game that really does show you
that these romantic era ideas are not
necessarily dead
and that's what i wanted to point out
with today's lecture to some extent
and to some other extent point out that
uh
you can't get away with everything as
those romantic players did
but here we see chucky playing e takes
d5 keeping things fresh
we see so they're going with knight
takes d5 uh
and here black actually does have a few
moves black can
sort of throw down the gauntlet and say
you take my pawn i take your pawn and
try to win material and this is perhaps
the the purest romantic aero way to play
black can also
try to keep things a little bit more
shut down with a move like e4
or black can play as swiddler did with
knight takes d5
now we see f takes c5 and white grabs a
ton of central space
and captures this last pawn but of
course
this comes at a cost so chat
what do you think svidler should play in
this position
dad just call him chucky yeah everybody
everybody calls him chucky
i did not invent that why not e takes f
looks stronger
e takes f is perfectly fine it's a
perfectly fine move
um just to show the line i think
continues
in any number of ways with d4 bishop c4
knight f3
even bishop check has been played they
just they do everything here
so you can't play e takes f but then
you know as always i guess d4 is perhaps
the
the most telling move to show you why
this is maybe not the greatest idea
because you give up
some central control but it's fine
anyways in the game
knight takes d5 f takes c5 and what
should fiddler do
and yeah fischer seb has the right idea
whenever you play
f4 you weaken this diagonal this is an
idea we actually saw
in that romantic game with knight takes
g2 but perhaps
it makes uh in appearance in a slightly
better form
in this game with knight takes c3 b
takes c3
and now queen h4 check and in this case
we actually see svidler going on the
attack early early on
because white perhaps got a little bit
too bold with capturing free pawns in
the center
and weakening the king's side
uh now in this case g3 runs into queen
e4 check
when the rook on h1 actually is free
this time uh as opposed to last game
so king e2 is forced and svidler now
gets a bit greedy
and this is what uh hands the advantage
back over
to ivan chuck here so what should be
done
well believe it or not as always the
best move
is to develop your pieces with something
like knight c6
something like bishop g4 check these
neither of these moves are perfectly
fine
and the reason for that is uh here
the damage has sort of been done to
white's position by virtue of having
this king
on e2 uh you know fans of a particular
opening
may disagree with me here but having the
king on e2
is sort of really really bad because
this bishop cannot move and the queen
cannot develop either
and just having this king in e2 is
compensation enough
for black in this position which is why
something like knight c6 something like
bishop g4
is the best way to keep the advantage
for black
instead though we see queen e4 check
which is with the idea of recapturing a
pawn on
e5 but now after king f2
white's fortunes have actually greatly
greatly improved with this
slight shuffling of the king from e2 to
f4 this critical tempo
now allows the bishop to develop it
allows this queen to breathe
and as we'll see it vacates the e file
for some very serious tactics in the
near near future
so just because we're not in the
romantic era doesn't mean
uh players aren't messing up these
really complex positions where things
sort of go crazy and break open
but before move ten right this is not an
idea that died in the 1800s ivan chuck
found a way to get svidler off guard uh
by allowing
some crazy stuff like queen h4 check
queenie for check
and what was fiddler's reward well
smithers reward was a worse position
due to the very same romantic ideas that
many people believe to be sort of dead
and gone
so sidler in romantic fashion
captured the material how else are you
supposed to do it
now we have knight f3 and this is the
classic romantic era dichotomy
that i keep talking about black
capturing free material
but white at the risk of his own king is
getting
development with tempo and ripping open
things
in front of the enemy king as well uh
what more can you ask for in a game
uh smither continues now with queen h5
and we see rook b1 which is a very
mature move that i don't think you would
see
in the 1800s but it goes back to this
idea that i was talking about in the
first game
where black had an advantage there
because black had a path to finish
developing the pieces
and quote unquote consolidate meaning
get the pieces out
get the king safe and go about your life
uh
in the middle game uh it you know a
promised land rarely reached in the
1800s the middle game
uh and so the idea of rook b1 is to
simply prevent black
from arriving at this fabled land of the
middle game by developing this bishop
now this bishop is tethered to the pawn
on b7
and we'll see this rook can eventually
potentially even enter the game via
other means as well
so very mature move rook b1 probably not
something you would see
in the 1800s but you know just goes to
show
that the attacking ideas have improved
along with the defensive ideas
now a6 is spidler's move and this
is a little bit beyond me here uh a6
is actually probably like the second
best move behind just developing
normally
but uh the idea is a little bit suspect
i i think
svidler was trying to prevent this exact
idea of rook b5 to e5
but a6 at the same time does feel like a
very very slow way to go about things
here
and it makes sense that it can and and
was punished
uh chucky continues now with queen e2
check
drawing out uh one of the bishops to
the e file if bishop e6 then
ideas of rook takes b7 are in the air
ideas of d4
with you know some some pushing ideas
are in the air
uh and so swiddler chooses bishop e7
now chat room how of course
of course how should white continue play
like a romantic
space communist in the chat is saying uh
be authentic to the time and use
descriptive notation
so yes bishop to kings
two right am i doing this correctly
and yeah the the famous vienna move the
famous romantic move the famous evans
gambit move bishop a3
of course this move this idea all the
way back from the 1800s
makes an appearance here you develop
this bishop out
by virtue in the evans gambit of a pawn
push to b4
and in this vienna gambit by virtue of
having recaptured on c3
this uh seemingly innocent change in
structure has allowed white to develop
quite quite quickly and bishop a3
as always comes with the idea of
planting this king firmly in the center
of the board
with no hope of castling so
stuff from the 1800s still present in
modern day chess
now we see knight c6 so they're
desperately trying to defend this bishop
uh and another really great mature move
by ivan chuck a movie probably
well a move you might see in the 1800s
but what's left you've made a bunch of
threats well of course you need to get
more pieces
into the game how do you do that well
simply queen e3
getting out of the way of the bishop and
preparing to bring the rook in
now queen f5 is fiddler's choice
which is a slightly strange looking move
but in fairness this weather
it is pretty tough to to come up with a
reasonable move here for black so
queen f5 was the best fiddler could come
up with right you can't really develop
this bishop again
because of rick takes b7 ideas
and if you can't develop this bishop
really really what can you do play rook
b8
seems unlikely okay so queen e3 and
queen f5 played in the game
now we see bishop takes c7 knight takes
c7 and the simple bishop d3 again
developing with tempo now we have queen
e6
and chucky sort of flinches at this
moment
uh instead of trying to keep up the
pressure with something like rig hd e1
he spies his opportunity to create a
weakness in the black camp with queen
takes e6
bishop takes his met with rook takes b7
still as i continually am mentioning
really highlighting the power of this
slightly slower looking rook b1 move
so f takes c6 and chucky goes on to win
this game
thanks to this weakness in black's camp
and thanks to the
you know just monstrous lead development
that white still has
without queens on the board so not quite
the romantic era you know 17 move
checkmate that we saw
in the previous game but just showing
that these vienna ideas these romantic
ideas
uh can still occasionally crop up in
your games of modern grand masters so
the romantic era
not dead still alive in the hands of the
silly ivan chuck or at least it was
11 years ago in 2009 now this is an
opening class so i don't want to spend
too much time
but i will show you sort of how this
game continues uh chucky plays rook he
won
bringing the rook into attack along the
e file we see h6
by svidler trying to keep the knight out
of the game
bishop c4 we get king f7 now and again
black is just fighting to to reach the
middle game at this point even with
queens off the board
uh we see rookie four uh preparing to
double rook d8 or
e1 knight d5 and yeah svidler
making his sort of final stand on the d5
square but now after knight d4
they're just too many pieces attacking
uh this weakness
b5 is played bishop b3 c5 now
knight c6 is the clever move by chucky
to reroute this knight to e5
and after c4 we see knight d3
and the pawns finally start dropping
zero takes e5 or takes e6 and svidler
throws in the towel
and resigns uh likely what's fiddler
missed here
was that black uh it is not actually
able to win any material
thanks to this bishop on c4 for example
knight takes er94 check was likely the
idea
double check king g1 but now after rook
takes e6
you're simply met with c5 and you have
problems that you cannot solve on the e6
square
so rook takes e6 and svidler go up goes
ahead
and resigns so like i said not the
romantic era checkmate
that we were maybe hoping for from the
start of this game
but it goes to show that you can be out
a book on move seven
in an opening like uh the vienna
with with black and even if your
position is good
as it often times was for black in the
romantic era
that doesn't necessarily mean you are
going to survive the game
in this case chucky gets a lot of those
same ideas that we saw in game number
one from the romantic era
in his game against peter swiddler but
again not quite the the romantic
checkmate that we could hope for
all right let us move along now to
another game
way back in the 1800s once again enough
on the vienna gambit
let us move along here
all right we have another game between
two
chess titans of the 1800s in henry
edward byrd
and wilhelm steinitz so
uh correct me if i'm wrong people who
know more about chess history than me
but it was sort of seen throughout
history
that steinis sort of ends the romantic
era once steinitz gets in full form
becomes the world champion you sort of
see
you know chess players quote unquote
maturing and moving away from from the
romantic style
um and i i don't know exactly how true
that was
steinitz definitely had his fair share
of romantic games from the winning side
and as we're about to see on his way
rising through the ranks
he definitely had his fair share of
beatdowns as well
at the hands of these other romantic
players so let's take a look
and see what bird was able to accomplish
against steinitz here
and bird does not play his namesake
opening of f4
but instead starts with e4 and e5 as
we've seen before
now we're going to see knight f3 knight
c6
and bishop b5 look at that the the roy
lopez
uh an opening we are all well
well acquainted with now knight f6
and we have arrived at the infamous
berlin defense you know and nowadays
everybody sees the berlin
they they take a deep breath and say oh
my gosh all right next game
this one's over i don't want to look at
this anymore but back in the romantic
era
it was not so not so clear what's going
on so let's see the romantic way to
handle the berlin
well as we often see in the romantic era
whenever black is sort of just
developing normally white gets bored and
plays the move d4 this is just
what you do in the romantic era right
you got to get your pieces
in the game what are you going to play
d3 like a passer what are you going to
take your time
to develop your pieces no i don't think
so you play d4
you open things up and you check me at
the black king that's how you do it
so pawn to d4 played in the game
now the obvious downside to this is that
both of these pawns could be captured
in this case black plays e takes d4 and
here we see white continuing out
with e5 as often happens
in openings like the scotch for example
or in this case this weird
scotch berlin sort of hybrid that's
going on
now we have knight e4 uh sort of what
else
should be played here this is often
times the correct response to the move
e5 early on
you just plant this knight in e4 with
the idea of supporting it out with the
pawn
to d5 and now
we have the move knight takes d4
by henry edward byrd so
what do you think's wrong with this
what's what's wrong with knight takes d4
here because if knight takes d4 weren't
wrong
then you might see a lot more people
sort of uh employing this this
line of play against the berlin after
all
why not it looks a lot more interesting
than that berlin end game we have seen
so so many times
what should black play here chat what do
we think
black to move
black to move in this position
and okay the the chat is actually coming
up with pretty much every
good move here so
one person in the chat had i think a
better idea
than the others and that is in the form
of knight takes f2 this is what you
should do
in the romantic era well actually it's
not what you should do in the romantic
era
simply because you're playing with the
black pieces what are you doing trying
to attack
with the black pieces in the romantic
era did you forget who moved first
did you forget but uh jokes aside
this probably is just a very strong
sacrifice
uh in in this position here king takes
f2
is essentially forced and now again
queen h4 check comes out with a double
attack
if you go g3 black's simply going to
capture on d4
and be much better so you have to try
king e3 but now bishop c5
and things are are quite scary
c3 is forced to keep the peace and now
really anything can be played
by black here you know castles d6
you know okay i say anything but really
castles or d6 should be played
and uh and black is is probably doing
quite well
uh in the position but black can also
sort of keep things simple with
something like
bishop c5 or the immediate queen h4 all
of these moves are fine
but knight takes f2 i think is is pretty
close to winning in the position
instead though we see in true romantic
style
the player with the black pieces keeping
things calm and conservative
and just developing out with bishop b7
so
another key difference that you might
not expect between the romantic players
of old
and the modern players today is that
they actually sometimes
do find more active options than
in today's chess than you would expect
right when you think romantic era you
think all these crazy sacrifices and
things like that
but there is this sort of strange
psychological block
in a lot of these games where the player
with the black pieces simply isn't
interested
in trying to attack at all they just
have no idea that this is like
a possibility right and i don't want to
overstate things
obviously there are some really nice
attacking games by the player with the
black pieces
in this romantic era but there is on
occasion this sort of mental block i've
noticed
where if they have the black pieces
they're just like yeah i moved second
it's my job to just sit back and defend
you know whatever happens happens tends
to be
the thinking uh okay so bishop b7
missing the opportunity to put on some
pressure with bishop c5 queen h4 or even
knight takes f2
and white simply castles uh and now
in kind we see black playing knight
takes d4
again perhaps with the idea of trading
stuff off and trying
to simplify things we have queen takes
d4
and i think this is a very intuitive
uh sorry very instructive idea that has
been played here so i want to pause
again
and ask the chat one more time what do
you think of this idea
by steinitz to take the knight on d4
good idea
bad idea you know fine idea doesn't
change too much
what do you think
manny is always surprised that they
ignore the free pawns yeah fair enough
you know
material means nothing when your games
end by move 20.
so yeah it's it's not a great move and
the reason
might not be what you expect the reason
isn't that knight takes e5 is a great
move
because as many e45 players will tell
you
when you stack too many pieces up on the
e file and your kings on e8
you're gonna get into trouble and that's
just the case here you can't be taking
this pawn on e5
when all your stuff is undefended d5 is
illegal
f5 doesn't really help for one they're
simply f3
when one of your pieces is going to fall
but knight takes d4 really only succeeds
in activating the white queen
right it's not so much that black is
removing an attacker
in exchange for a defender here it's
sort of like black is activating white's
queen for free
not only for free but doing it with
tempo on blackstone hanging night
and this tempo just simply could have
much been better spent with kingside
castles
when ideas of knight takes e5 may
potentially be in the air a little bit
later
or at the very least black is going to
be able to
complete development with something like
d5 activating this bishop
defending this knight and getting into
the game completely
once again castles trying to reach a
middle game okay and i'm going to say it
again
for the romantic players who are all
long dead middle game
it's something that exists in chess
beyond the opening
all right beyond the opening there is
more chess to be had
but no such luck in this game uh as we
do see knight takes d4 queen takes d4
in knight c5 uh howls to defend the
knight again d5
is illegal so knight c5 played in the
game
and now of course you know bird is not
in the business of
developing the pieces and entering the
middle game
he's in the business of attacking so we
see f4
with a total disregard for stacking the
pieces up
on this uh diagonal here and just ready
to come and attack black's king
of course you know why not after all and
now we see steinitz engaging
in sort of uh some some hope chess
that will be familiar to many people in
the chat with the move b6
so who sees the idea behind b6
who sees what steinins had up his sleeve
here
and of course if you want to try to find
it for yourself you can pause
but b6 is very cleverly adding a
defender
to the c5 square allowing perhaps the
tactic we see in the game
of knight b3 with the idea of bishop c5
pinning queen to king and punishing bird
for uh the insolent f4 uh
setting himself up for disaster here so
what does bird do
does he say oh my god you're gonna take
my rook on a1 and then i'm gonna lose
in the end game the whats no of course
not bird says
i don't care about my rook on a1 because
i'm going to check me chew in 15 moves
because that's how chess is played in
the 1800s so bird plays f5
uh senates you know being a good
romantic player at this time
does play the move knight b3 saying yeah
i'm gonna take your free rook and then
because i'm playing with the black
pieces
i will defend and then win the game with
my extra material
so white of course plays queen to e4
steinitz captures on a1 and now
white to move white to move and try to
win
the game how do we knock him dead here
how do we knock him dead do we take the
rook on a8
hint the answer is no we do not take the
rope on a8
we do not take the rook on a8s
so yeah as the chat says we should go f6
and just checkmate the the black king
it's not always correct to just blindly
play for mate like this
as they did in the romantic era but in
this case it is pretty good
uh we see bishop c5 check trying to step
out of the threat with tempo on the king
king h1 you know what else and stein
it's been good romantic error player
said my rook is attacked
i have to save it because i'm playing
with the black pieces if i were playing
with the white pieces i would allow you
to take my rook and checkmate you but
playing with the black pieces i better
save the material
and now a white chooses one of the many
ways to win
with the very very beautiful e6
and here here stein instead had enough i
believe and went ahead
and resigned the game uh the game might
have continued with something like f
takes e6
of course d takes d6 is illegal but now
of course
queen take c6 is going to be played
king f8 means f takes g7
and bishop h6 for the final checkmate
bringing in another attacker and killing
the king
and believe it or not there just isn't a
good response to the movie e6 there's
just
nothing to do here if you try to take
this one
uh then e takes d7 is good enough with
kf8 bishop h6
again coming in handy with checkmate
if you try to play anything else again
there's really nothing else to play you
can
castle but now e7 is a pretty nasty fork
queen e8 for example and then not only
do we have
things like e takes f8 but we also have
things like bishop d3
uh threatening checkmate and even here
for example queen h4 ends this is this
is just busted
just busted so steins throws in the
towel after e6
and we have yet another romantic era
game ending by move 15
and black having a full belly with full
belly with brook
on a1 so what happened this game
well of course it all comes down to this
sort of
mental block that players seem to have
in the 1800s on occasion
where with the black pieces they were
very very reluctant to go for mating
attacks
just because you know they sort of had
to play with the second move
so ideas of knight takes f2 ideas of
bishop c5 ideas of queen h4 all
these ideas were in fact missed and
after bishop e7 white is quite simply
just
just better practically and objectively
so
let's again take a look at how some
modern day players approached this
position uh as
i again am skipping ahead
well in this game we have uh gadir
gusenov
uh with the white pieces and alexi
shirov playing with black
and we have the exact same opening we
have knight c6 bishop b5 knight f6
and the berlin defense and gusynov does
try this d4
idea this is not an idea that died in
the romantic era
playing d4 against the berlin is still a
reasonable way to play and after e takes
d4
even e5 has been tried on numerous
occasions
so after knight e4 we have the exact
same position
uh but here kusanov you know does not
play knight takes d4
when white again is simply worse after
any of these moves i believe
and instead castles the king fair enough
castle the king defend f2
don't fall for these tricks uh now we
have the idea
of a6 and the point now is that if you
want to retreat this guy
black is going to start gaining tempe on
your pieces and
develop quickly get castled and again be
perfectly fine
so we do see whites capturing on c6
instead
now we have d take c6 and knight takes
d4 in the game
and now bishop c5 developing with tempo
uh and this this is again just the right
idea
for black in this case you you don't
sort of
naively develop slowly with something
like bishop e7
you look for active counter play despite
having the black pieces
with bishop c5 and now black is
perfectly fine
we see c3 and kingside castles rookie
one
and now uh with black having
uh developed out uh in the opening black
can now afford to play the weakening
move of f5 a move that really wasn't
ever playable
with the black king stuck on e8 but with
the rook on f8 this diagonal open
black is is very very much ready to open
up this diagonal and defend the knight
on e4
and be perfectly fine the game continues
now with f3
knight back to g5 bishop out to e3
and f4 by alexey shirov we see bishop f2
in 96 and yeah black just has no problem
queen b3
queen d5 and we see some trades
bishop out to e6 bishop takes on d5
and yet again the berlin makes its way
towards an end game and while this end
game
may look like it has some potential for
white with the these powerful looking
central pawns in fact black really
doesn't have any issues here with the
powerful white square blockade
ideas of breaking these pawns down with
c5 and
just very very free pieces so again
nothing doing against the berlin sorry
to anybody who thought this
d4 idea was going to be the big
refutation uh
all the way back from the romantic era
of course black does turn out to have
some pretty good responses
now again as we are pretty far from the
opening i don't want to spend too much
time
but after many many moves this game does
end up
being agreed uh to a draw with
some shuffling uh when white has no way
to break the blockade
black isn't really interested in
changing the structure with something
like c5 just yet
and we are going to see nothing happen
for the remainder of the game
okay so questions on this berlin stuff
here
questions here
all right well
let us move along to one more romantic
era game
and one more modern day game if we do
have the time
curious how the players 300 years ago
dealt with any sort of end games as we
know them nowadays
i don't know what you're talking about
manny the end game wasn't invented in
the 1800s
um that is a modern day trick
used by grand masters to make you
believe
that you shouldn't spend all your time
studying the king's gambit
so speaking of the king's gambit and
speaking of paul morphy who i didn't
mention but paul morphy perhaps was the
only player with any sort of endgame
knowledge
back in the day uh of course that's an
exaggeration but
paul morphy of course was sort of miles
ahead of
other players in his day uh well
what am i saying i'm saying it wouldn't
be a romantic era lecture without a game
from paul murphy and it wouldn't be a
romantic era lecture without a game in
the king's gambit
so here we're gonna kill two birds with
one stone as we see
paul morphy employing the king's gambit
to great success in this game
against eugene rousseau we of course
have the king's game but accepted
because it is black's duty to capture
free material and then defend for his
life
we now see knight f3 g5 what else you
captured the material now you have to
defend it
h4 trying to break down black's defense
of the f-pawn
and now g4 by black
forcing the knight away and trying to
keep everything together
nowadays at the top level you are going
to see the move 95 played in this
position and if we have time we will
take another look
at a game that actually does go 95 but
paul murphy in this case
goes with knight g5 and this is simply
uh too much for present day chess in my
opinion
and to rosso's credit he actually finds
the refutation
he says wait a second that square's
covered
that square is covered that square is
covered
these squares are covered 94 is illegal
what if i attack your knight and the
answer is uh white must sacrifice it
with knight takes f7
so we do actually see all of this happen
knight f7 king f7
and now queen takes g4 by paul morphy
and uh in modern day chess there
are actually some games here between
like some 2300s even up to a 2400 one
time
and they all go knight c3 or d4 or
bishop c4 check
something boring developing the minor
pieces in the opening
but opening principles weren't invented
yet so instead we see queen takes g4
with the idea of putting the queen near
the king and hoping checkmate happens
uh okay and i should say that this this
opening line is probably just winning
for black uh an extra piece is an extra
piece
and as you might expect the refutation
sort of just involves black breaking in
the center developing pieces
playing knight f6 playing bishop b4 just
just
normal chess moves that that you would
expect
so queen takes g4 played and now black
has a few ways to maintain the advantage
the easiest of which is knight f6 when
after queen takes f4
bishop d6 can be played and the folly of
white's queen takes g
queen takes g4 is a 1 is one that should
be
pretty apparent to most chess beginners
even who have always been told of course
if you develop the queen out early
you're going to lose time because it's
going to get kicked around by the minor
pieces
and that is exactly true here black
maintains a winning advantage
by protecting the king and developing
the pieces and gaining time on the queen
all uh sort of simultaneously
of course e5 isn't playable because
bishop takes c5 and rookie 8 would be
winning the queen so bishop d6
and black is is just winning for example
queen e3 and black can even go so far
as to take on e4 with impunity thanks to
this rookie 8 idea
easily winning but rosso plays the move
queen of six instead
countering the enemy queen with his own
very clever idea checkmate me now
well paul morphy attempts to do just
that with the move bishop c4 check
we see king e7 of course now these ideas
of d5
aren't necessarily working because white
has enough attackers on the square
so king e7 forced now we see knight c3
making a threat so this is black's last
opportunity
to maintain an advantage so i do want to
ask the chat room
if you have this position with the black
pieces can you find the way
to stay in the driver's seat here
can you find the way
funslot says c6 manny says c6
any other ideas c6 and dominate the
knight
i wonder if the chat is aware are you a
where chat room
your night is hanging are you aware of
this
did anybody tell you your night is
attacked
two two times two times
it's crazy it's crazy
um so long story short it turns out the
only way
for black to maintain an advantage is to
play the awkward looking move
king to d8 now what's the point of this
move
well the point is bishop takes g8 is not
quite working
thanks to the idea of h5
uh black is or sorry white is not
completely lost thanks to the idea of
knight to d5 sorry when uh white is
somehow sort of miraculously trying to
keep
the pieces even but black is still going
to have an advantage after takes takes
bishop b7 and e5 when
takes takes takes does leave black
with an extra piece although white does
have you know some slight compensation
thanks to the extra h pawn this bishop
coming out
and for the moment this f pawn does
remain on the board
so kd8 was the key move the key move to
allow you to develop your pieces
right it all comes down to this
developing idea
instead though c6 played in the game
and we see paul morphy striking
immediately back with e5
which is still not correct but is the
romantic way to play
so what should white have done instead
well white should of course
be aiming to get more pieces into the
game with the move d4
or d3 even just activating pieces as
quickly as
as quickly as possible now king d8
would of course be met by bishop takes
f4 when white is actually
on the plus side of things uh instead
though morphy not one to wait around
plays e5 baiting queen takes c5 so that
white
white can play the move king d1
threatening
rook to e1 uh the unfortunate news of
this
is that it essentially forces black to
play the good move which is king d8
bringing the king off of the e file yes
but also clearing the way
to potentially develop this bishop out a
little bit later on
we do see the move rookie one bringing
the rook into the game
now queen c5 and this is the critical
mistake
by black i i don't know why
black didn't play the move queen g7 this
seems like the most natural move
your knight is attacked after all and
this defends it keeps the queen
around the king it allows you to develop
out on the next turn
for example this move d5 even it should
be seven
any any move is is good here for black
but instead queen out to c5 and now in
fact
yes this knight on g8 is hanging we see
d5 by
black hitting the queen but this does
not do enough
after the key move here so white to move
and win
see if you guys can checkmate like paul
morphy
can you do it can you check me like
morphy
and they played queen c5 that's right
harry they missed all the wins
played queen c5 but thankfully it does
give us this beautiful romantic finish
as the chat is now uh showing with the
move rookie 8 check
drawing the king away and undefending
the bishop on c8
and now morphy does go on to win in
style with
the key follow-up here which everybody
saw from afar
everybody saw the follow-up from afar i
know you all did
i know you didn't say rookie 8 check
queen see it without seeing the follow
up
i'm just going to give you a moment to
type it in the chat i know you all
already saw it
queen c7 not queen c7 if you play queen
c7
then uh knight d7 by black is good but
yes knight takes d5
taking advantage of the pin on the c
pawn
not a pin you see every day with the
pawn being pinned
in this manner from behind but it is a
good pin
in this case even making use of this
bishop back on g8
now the king simply has nowhere to go
and is checkmated on the next turn with
king d6
queen c7 checkmates and with that
paul morphy wins the game so
pretty wild game here by morphy but he
does end up
getting to the desired destination uh
after all
uh now we only have a few minutes but i
do want to show you the modern day
follow-up to this game which uh i went
back to alexis shiraf for
turns out this alexi shirov guy he was a
pretty romantic player
uh played a lot of really interesting
ideas you know you could describe them
as fiery on occasion i i would say
so let's see the the way to do it here
we have
of course the king's gambit knight f3 g5
we're going to go down
the same line but yes we are going to be
looking at 95
because this knight g5 takes up seven
move it's it's just not good black just
has more pieces
and it's just not good uh we see d6 by
alexis shirov
trying to tempt white into sacrificing
this knight but
the reason why knight e5 is played over
knight g5
is because now white is going to retreat
back to g4
and keep an even number of pieces on the
board
black now develops out with knight f6
and white
can capture on f6 and as is the main
line or play the move knight f2
as played in this game but now we are
actually going to see
a huge reversal of roles here something
you don't often see in the romantic era
but you played one too many retreating
moves here with the white pieces
you moved this knight now four times and
in the meantime black has played d6
developing a bishop
black has played knight f6 developing a
knight and so
now we actually actually see
alexis shiroff going on the offensive
straight out of the opening
starting with rook g8 uh sort of some
comparisons that you can draw to ivan
chuck's rook
b1 in the previous game keeping this
bishop on the f1 square
tethered down to g2 as always
preventing your phone your opponent from
natural development
is a huge huge part of any gambit any
early attack
you need to keep your opponent from
developing naturally otherwise
your attack just simply isn't going to
work and this is the idea
of rook g8 we continue out with d4 with
the white pieces
and now bishop h6 uh and again
comparisons you can draw
to the vienna bishop a3 in this case
though black is aiming to
keep the f4 pawn not because you know
black doesn't want to be down a pawn
but because this f4 pawn is a really
useful attacker
we now see knight c3 in knight c6
developing out
now knight d5 by white does turn out to
be a pretty fatal mistake here
uh white is already sort of just worse
in this knight f2 line but knight d5
sort of seals the deal you see knight
takes d5 e takes d5
queen e7 check now if queen e2
you could expect to see the simple
knight takes d4
when there's simply no good way to
defend against all the threats in the
position
uh if you play king d1 simply bishop f5
and you know things are tough so instead
we see
bishop e2 which is in fact a better try
but now black maintains an advantage
with knight b4
again coming after this stuff and also
keeping an eye on d5
we see white sort of play c4 almost
naively
trying to keep everything together but
bishop f5
activates and now we see again white is
just unable to comfortably complete
development and that is going to be the
downfall
so bishop f5 and in true romantic style
shirov is actually sacrificing the
knight in this position queen a4 check
can and should be played
checking the king and attacking the
knight at the same time
and there's no good response king f8 and
whites up a piece
but of course the story doesn't end
there with white's king stuck in the
center
sheriff plays rookie 8 hitting the
bishop queen d2
and then the key move of the not the key
move of the game just yet
but the natural move rick takes g2 uh
comes on the board and this is
the downside to developing the bishop
you do leave this pawn on g2 hanging
we see king f1 rook g3 just retreating
back
keeping this king in sort of in a cage
now queen d1 is played desperately
trying to develop
but bishop e4 is hitting the rook you
see rook h2
now f5 secures this bishop on e4
knight takes e4 played but f takes e4 is
good enough
when now the pawns are useful attackers
bishop g4 played in the game
we see e3 bishop f3 queen to g7
making a threat so rook back oh
shouldn't have done that accidentally
clicked inspect element but okay rook h1
and now the key move of the game chat
room the key move of the game black to
move and
end the game this move is so powerful it
ends the game
what do you guys have for me
what do you guys have black to move and
end the game
he streams nowadays i didn't know this i
didn't know this
uh you guys will have to uh to drop
share of a follow on twitch i assume i
didn't know he was streaming that's
actually really cool
everybody says pawn to e2 everybody says
pawn to e2 you're all jokesters
you're all jokesters bishop takes e2
free pawn
free pawn black's not even better after
e2
there's a lot of winning moves but e2 is
not not the way e2 is not the way rook
takes f3 and e2
okay i don't even think this one's
either free stuff
i'll move i'll move out of the way you
guys doing
move of the game you got to end the game
you got to get the guy
here he likes the e2 i like the e2 idea
i just don't like the e2
move
all right we're low on time here if you
guys want to stick around and try to
find it
i encourage you to pause the video now
uh turns out like any
nothing move you know keeps the winning
advantage but the knockout blow
is in fact rook g2 with yes
this e2 idea but this is the way to make
it work
what's the point well the point is if
captures then e2 check
takes and if king takes queen takes g2
is
more than enough to win the game and
if you think you can get away with
ignoring this
for example rook f2 check is going to be
quite good with queen g3 to follow
and you're just you're busted here
you're busted here rook f3 is
sort of impossible to stop uh and
as for other moves i don't know what
other moves there there really are like
if you
do this or something i'll just take it
and you have all the same problems
all the same problems so rook g2 the
killer final move
that uh gets uh the the opponent alexei
futerov
to resign in this case uh so i went
through that game really quickly because
we were sort of short on time
but i just wanted to show that these
romantic attacking games
they they exist in today's chess they
are a lot less common
than they were in the romantic era but
these romantic ideas
still have their place in today's chess
uh albeit with
some some amendments you know the
emphasis on preventing development i
think
is a lot more present than it was back
in the day and
you know players do tend to value pawns
more than
zero which i feel like was their
appropriate value
in the 1800s hopefully you guys enjoyed
this lecture
on romantic era openings and how they
look in modern day chess
as well if you're watching live i would
encourage you to head on over
to the twitch channel where we are going
to do some tactics time with new
updated tactics on leachat should be fun
should be fun
but aside from that that is where i am
going to call today's lecture
so i want to thank you guys very much
for watching as i flip over here and
don't play the intro again
i want to thank you guys very much for
watching as always my name is caleb
denby
and i will see you next time
you